don't want to try potsticker I'm okay
right now but thank you though hi guys
my name is great some people do that no
99 your life is different now welcome to
the first grace member fun day [ __ ]
Monday's is basically a sexy and/or sex
and Orlov type of video you see the
title of this video I'm going to attempt
to do a 6 ball pumpkin spice inspired
makeup look because I went on Pinterest
and I looked up a bunch of fall inspired
makeup looks and here's the damp one I'm
genuinely going to try and - we don't
remember what - was probably a lot like
one I'm gonna kind of use all of the
photos that I've seen on picture and
just sort of push them all together into
a vision board for what I'm going to
smack onto my face though I do have an
idea that might manifest itself later in
this video we'll see how lazy I get
let's do it
I'm exhausted just I'm trying to explain
what this is before it starts Brooks do
you have something you think about when
you think about fall inspired makeup
pumpkin corn uh you said orange orange
is also another inspiration and corn can
also be another form of inspiration
because this look might be hard to
digest
I have foundation on my face already but
I'm gonna put some more foundation on
because this looks way not correct to
the color of my arm skin let's balance
it out this hasn't changed anything this
works for me oh yeah that made this look
way better somehow
I've been my lips look identical to a
butt hole and it wasn't even dry but
maybe that's fall related cuz fall means
like school starting again
so like clenched [ __ ] might be an
actual thematic element involved and I
like it what was the plan eyes is Carley
Jenner eyeshadow palette that I bought
last year and you can tell cause look
how gross it is which ones are called
I don't know because I had my grubby
hands I've scraped up this looks like
just a herd of grubby toddlers somehow
I'll play football with this because all
of these very old
colors so we're gonna try and make our
eyes look like pumpkin spice latte we're
gonna start out with guess what just
straight up orange we're gonna go pretty
heavy-handed on this Wow who is she
unapproachable
that's a she's kind of second guessing
that orange is a basecoat
Wow there's gonna swirl a bunch of
colors and hope for the best
let's do now a darker color for the
other part of the eye she's very good at
describing makeup tutorial this one oh
that looks like a garbage fire happened
on top of my eyelid it doesn't seem to
be blending neither does a pumpkin spice
latte with my digestive system yeah
that's like I can't fire on my eyelid
that work let's do that over here too
doesn't it look like the Pinterest girls
let's blend a neutral color and see if
that blends but wow
someone has eyelid let's put more orange
on remember this is [ __ ] Monday's so we
want this to look sexy and make a
business sexy unless there's 20 pounds
of it on your face let's put some of it
the eyeshadow under our eyes girls do
that and that seems right we want to
make it look like we don't sleep but
that's really looks a little bit like I
had a very sexy disease it's not the
worst so far take this color that looks
a little shimmery and try and put it in
the middle part oh wow it did nothing
now let's put some black eyeliner on
because black eyeliner is always sexy
every New Jersey girl grows up learning
the black eyeliner is mayn't like
foundation of your makeup foundations
not the foundation black eyeliner is the
foundation this is how much of my black
eyeliner is left because the jersey
never stops we're gonna put this on kind
of sloppily and then smudge it in and
then maybe but liquid liner over and
I'll put it on her waterline ah oh wow
there she is
now we're gonna smudge that in with a
brush whoa cool budget make it smoke you
like you're making Thanksgiving dinner
and
and you forgot that the stove was on Wow
that looks like a very polluted sunset
okay then we're gonna smudge under the
eye a little bit oh I don't have fake
eyelashes so okay I'm going to use an
eyelash primer and then put mascara over
top of it every girl turns into Robert
DeNiro when they put any sort of eyelash
mascara on so if you didn't know what
eyelash primer was it's just white crazy
stuff that goes on your eyelashes before
you put the actual mascara on and
supposed to plump up your eyelashes to
give you the illusion that maybe got
falsies on it's just another way to look
really crazy in the process too trying
to look hot and attractive I want to
blend out this eyeshadow a little bit
now to put mascara on we go alright
there's that here's the deal we're gonna
do a normal face meaning I'm gonna fill
my eyebrows in put some bronzer and
blush on and do my lip and then we're
gonna kick it up a notch so let's do our
eyebrows normal first seems like an
eyebrow mm-hmm eyebrows that's good
now that's put some bronzer I'm going
really hard that seems like bronzer
that's what blush on yay okay now let's
do lips don't know how to do ombre lips
but I kind of want to I have this really
dark maroon and this orange I'm gonna
combine them to see what happens because
[ __ ] Mondays oh yeah why does it look
like my mouth tilted to the side
yeah that's kind of it so this is a
totally normal fine fall look inspired
by Pinterest fall looks wah but let's
try an ombre these lips how do we hombre
these lips question how do you Superman
that ho
I don't want answers to the follow-up
but if you just said orange in the
middle this is all wrong oh is that it
all right that's just a different cut of
color that's an ombre that's so this is
a fall look that you could stop at and
say look how tamil I am whoa very
Pinterest very Instagram makeup face
model except
[Music]
but I'm gonna push it a step further
since eyebrows have been so trendy to
[ __ ] with in terms of makeup and get
really inspired by fall leaves and see
what I can make of my eyebrows but that
is my inspiration I'm taking this brown
eyeliner pencil yes
as it is now let's take our liquid liner
go over that wow wow okay now let's fill
it in with some orange whoa honestly to
myself this could not be more inspired
by and could not be more of a go-to
everyday makeup look it only took me 45
minutes well there you go
there's my fault um no pumpkin spice
pumpkin etc inspired makeup look let me
know you guys think of the comments down
below if you attempt this on your own
tag me on Instagram and Twitter so I can
see all of your beautiful fall inspired
creation don't forget to subscribe to
this YouTube channel I'm looking at
himself in the viewfinder because I am
just enamored with this don't forget to
subscribe to this YouTube channel guys
are making videos Monday through Friday
through the month of Grace vembur the
greatest hashtag that's ever lived other
than that I don't know do ya you want to
see let me know if you think it's fall
inspired it's a real world takes a
second to process you're gonna get
looked at and the girl that wears this
kind of look wants to get looked at
exactly this is taking wigle eyebrows up
to a new fall seasonal level that's true
so this works for a lot of seasonal
events and activities or if you were
trying to get banged at a funeral
uh-huh yeah ideally this is the look
that you would wear to a new significant
others family members funeral like if
you haven't ever met their family before
and you just want to let them know I'm
gonna make your son and/or daughter's
life different than it is this is who
you have sex with after you've had your
heart broken by the one you
and you go to the bar and you're like
you had those tattooed on your eyes I
don't give up I'm desperate yeah I've
done